I have been robbed I was working with a
crackhead what were you guys working on
a remix like a like a group project no
like we were doing this business where
they would bring me stolen goods and
then I'll give them credit for suab to
to gamble so you're a lone shark
literally she was a thug so so then can
I say allegedly as your a lawyer maybe
you should they about to catch a RICO
they brought something after we gave
them the credit they also took the item
back and just ran for some reason that's
still stealing but he did get beat up
you deserve that but I had a soft spot
like honestly I feel like that's the
problem yes because I'm just like we're
not doing good business either so who am
I to was the nonprofit called crack for
craps that's a good name no